my name is Gary haugen and I'm president
of international justice mission and I
want to answer the question that Elaine
Walters sent it and she asked please
tell us what you care about what future
direction you seek and how you'll
contribute to improving the state of the
world what I care about is the way that
the poor in our world are so vulnerable
to violence and what I care about is
trying to actually protect the pool from
most basic forms of violence you know we
think of people who are poor we think of
people who are hungry or are sick or
maybe homeless and sometimes we don't
understand that the poor actually just
utterly vulnerable to violence all forms
of sexual violence illegal detention
slavery there are 27 million slaves in
our world today of course those are
overwhelmingly very very poor people
they face violently being thrown off
their land or being thrown in prison and
how the world could do we extract those
reports to be able to move forward if
they can't be safe from violence you can
give all kinds of goods and services to
the poor but if we don't restrain the
bullies from taking those benefits away
then we're probably going to be
disappointed what we were able to
achieve so I'm looking forward to seeing
a future in which the poorest in our
world get what we all get to have here
at the World Economic Forum and that's
this protection from forces of violence
you know here in Davos there's housings
of well trained law enforcement that are
protecting us and keeping us safe and
they everyone here understands that you
need that kind of protection just to be
safe from those who prey upon you but
that's exactly what the poor need they
also need access to excellent law
enforcement or the truth is they live in
a state of de facto lawlessness so what
I'm hoping is that we talk about
building and improving the state of the
world that will improve the state of the
world for everybody because if you're
not safe nothing else matters and we
want to see a world in which everybody
is safe for violence